if a and b are constants and the graph
of G of X is equal to the square of x
minus a plus B has its minimum at G of
six which of the following pairs of
points could also be on the graph of G
of X in the X Y plane to solve this
problem sketch a parabola that has its
minimum along X is equal to six then if
two pairs of points have the same Y
coordinates their x coordinates must
have the same distance to X is equal to
six in answer Choice a the pairs of
points have the same Y coordinates but
their x coordinates have different
distances to X is equal to six so this
is wrong in answer Choice C the two
pairs of points have the same distance
to X is equal to six but their Y
coordinates are not equal to each other
in answer Choice B since 0 6 is a point
we would expect 12 6 to also be a point
therefore the point where X is equal to
10 would have a y coordinate that's less
than 6. finally answer Choice D the two
pairs of points have the same Y
coordinates and their x coordinates have
the same distance to X is equal to six
so the correct answer is d